[Music]
how is héctor mejía greeting you with his
brief informative for today wednesday
august 4th appears in court today
moreno rodríguez is indicted to be formally charged with
the murder of his son the
grand jury has been evaluating
evidence on the death of the child who
was  found lifeless by
hikers in may of being found
guilty moreno rodríguez could
face the death penalty the
hotel company in resorts has sold the
land where the engine hotels are located
the adif company for peris
bought the land for 17 billion the
sale still  It needs the approval of
regulators but it is anticipated that it will be
completed by the beginning of the year.
The Bichi Propolis company also bought
the land where the Sisters Hotel is located
and is one of the companies that
acquired Las Vegas' Sean Se this past
March and a reminder to  drivers
with the return to school the police
restarted the traffic operation in
school zones  As of today, the
road elements
present in pedestrian crossings located
near primary and secondary schools are
asking drivers to slow
down and be aware of
signs and lights in school zones.
The first day of school is Monday,
August 9. Today the new  resorts world hotel and casino
will offer vaccines and
tests for the coronavirus this is for
anyone over the age of
12 the clinic will be open from
10 am to 6 pm and is
located on the second floor of the
arquette bourne ballroom now  a look at
the weather forecast we will have
heat warnings until tomorrow
temperatures exceeding 110 degrees
however there will be some breezes for
thursday and friday that will lower the
temperatures a little with a maximum close
to 105 degrees have a nice wednesday
i am héctor mejía and this  was its brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]